chlamydia is a sexually transmitted
pathogen and it can lead to sexually
transmitted disease it's intracellular
parasite which cannot produce their own
ATP and they have they lack the
classical peptidoglycan rendering in a
beta-lactam antibiotics to be
ineffective that stereotypes a B and C
are implicated in keratoconjunctivitis
which leads to severe inflammation of
the eye and eventually corneal clouting
serotype D and K are implicated in
pelvic inflammatory disease
non-gonococcal urethritis Etc in females
there are pelvic there are symptoms
including pelvic inflammatory disease
chronic pain infertility ectopic
pregnancy and premature birth in case of
males there are symptoms like
epidim or chidis inflammation in the
testicles reactive arthritis and
inflamed rectum there are different zero
types which are implicated in different
types of disease and here is The quick
summary
watch the full video to know more